if I were asked what are the greatest
global threats to health today I would
divide that into two parts one of course
would be the biology the Ebola Zika bird
flu swine flu world and I will talk
about that but far more than that are
the kind of centrifugal forces that are
pulling us apart as a nation pulling us
apart as a world the deterioration of
all of the International and national
organization that we depend upon to keep
us safe the World Health Organization
which failed to protect the world
against Ebola and didn't do a great job
on Zika either
and it will have a new leader in May of
this year a couple candidates who are
terrific and some that aren't so good
but either way WHU show is going to be
going through a period of years of
introspection and reorganization we have
a new Secretary General of the UN he's a
good guy from Portugal Gutierrez he just
started it'll be a while before he can
find all the bathrooms and UN buildings
we've just lost the head of CDC we have
a new acting head of CDC who is also
good but CDC will go through a headless
period and then we have Trump and we
have a White House which would almost
reflex ly discard anything that had the
word public in it and one of those words
is Public Health and they have not shown
a keen interest in pandemics and the
whole idea of America first which might
be good for many things is singularly
not good for a global pandemic just it's
an oxymoron it doesn't work
these centrifugal forces that put us in
a period of vulnerability are the
gravest threats
on the biology side in the last 30 years
we've had 30 novel heretofore unknown
diseases that jumped from animals to
humans they're almost all viruses and in
addition to Ebola and Zika and bird flu
and swine flu
we have corona viruses like SARS and
MERS we have Harbor viruses and a lot of
other viruses that continue to to jump
at the rate of about one a year that
that rate is increasing slightly it
isn't I don't think it's it's not
increasing at a catastrophic rate the
causes of its increasing are that
animals and humans are living in each
other's habitat now more than ever part
of that is the clear cutting of forests
to grow soybeans and things of that
nature another reason is that as
countries have gotten slightly more
wealthy they begin to consume more
protein and more animal protein I
remember when I worked at Google I gave
a talk to 3,000 young Indian Googlers in
Hyderabad and I asked them to raise
their hand if their grandparents were
vegetarian they all raised their hand
then I asked them to raise their hand if
their parents were vegetarians and about
1/2 raise their hand and I asked if they
were vegetarians and no one raised their
hand and I think that's that leads to
the increase in chickens and pigs that
we've been seeing in China and India not
not that pig selection in India that
means that the kind of way in which in
Asia houses and farms are all together
and you can go to Laos and see a pancake
house that has pigs on the ground for
chickens in the middle and humans up on
top and when the pigs are eating what's
left of them is fed to the chickens and
when the chickens are eating what's left
of them it's fed to the pigs and of
course everything's fed to humans that's
like a natural
Pyrus experiment you really wouldn't
want to do that if you if you were
trying to keep the world safe from
viruses so we are having more viruses
jump from animals to humans for lots of
different reasons related to modernity
and normally our ability to protect the
world keeps a pace with that maybe even
is a little bit ahead and every year
were a little bit safer that's not true
right now right now because of the
reorganization and nationalism and the
reorganization and dislike for the
United Nation and its agencies I think
we're in a period of grave all nerdy so
it's those two things together
[Music]